well we you don't apologize to us but we
we love you regardless but
uh do you do you are you super hard on
yourself
like do you always stress about like
when you film something afterwards
you're like recreating the moments and
the scenes
you still do that oh sure yeah i can
tear myself apart by the time i get home
yeah think like what did i do how do you
shut it off how do you just let it go
you think at your age by now
you would be able to think right because
because i want
to have some kind of semblance of hope
that when i maybe i turn
60s 70s i'll stop giving a but you
don't stop giving a
right but sometimes i get uh
overly uh paranoid i i have tendency to
for paranoia i think it came from hiding
so long
from hiding about who i really am your
sexuality
huh your sexual actuality yeah yeah i
had to
i pretended for a long time and what was
so
interesting was that i remember
confessing to my to my um my
my relatives down in virginia my
cousin patty who's nine years older than
me known me since
i was born i mean she was nine when i
was born so i've known
her forever and i confessed to her why i
sort of lost communication because i was
living with
somebody and my mother wanted it to stay
among the family which meant the three
of us
and she just looked at me and she said
oh johnny we've known you've been gay
since you were a little boy
wow it doesn't slow doesn't that make
you feel sad
that you lost so much contact when she
would have really understood you or she
didn't understand you yeah yeah yeah
that was that's what's happening
waste of time and that's why i sort of i
guess
when it came time to just to stop
it i just stopped and i
but i still sometimes feel like a
second rate because of it what do you
mean second rate
well it's because i'm i'm different than
the other boys
it was it was hard especially when it
got to junior high school and
and high school and stuff when you know
i was
uncomfortable so but i found i found my
strength
in the theater i uh we
we did a lillium
the play called lillium which was
carousel was based on that musical
and and you had readings in the
cafeteria and i just
read one little line i thought i did it
really well but they didn't notice me
so i got on the crew to change the stage
it was platforms in the cafeteria it was
in the round
so people had to carry things on and off
and i got a
black derby cap and a black turtleneck
and black pants
and i came out and started moving the
furniture and people started laughing
at me so i don't know what i was doing
but i was behaving in him i didn't say a
word
but by the end of the show i was getting
big laughs and i thought the teacher was
going to be
really really mad at me but she gave me
the play of the lead in the play the
next year
wow i guess and i could make people
laugh i had i had a control
something happened and and and they were
i was making them laugh and they were
laughing at me enjoying themselves
and it felt so good especially probably
because you were going through such a
tough time
i know you're hiding that this is a
chance right right this is your problem
i could be somebody else
and they would appreciate that did you
it was the me
i remember once i i carol kane was a
good friend of mine
and she was uh um
you know the blonde
the blonde girl from from terry garr
somehow i i got alone with terry garr in
her house
you've never seen me i've i felt so
uncomfortable
like i should be somebody that i should
be some man here
with terry gar in the house and i was
like this gay guy that didn't know what
to say to her
i just made myself so uncomfortable i
make myself uncomfortable around
bernadette peters
i i have such a crush on her and i saw
her when she was in high school and one
of the first things she did in new york
so and and i got to uh to do a
we did a tv movie together so i got to
play with her
and i just would go and once we were all
sitting around
talking and and she said i have a sister
and i said i'm an
only child and she said oh no wonder
you're a little chatterbox
you